I have here many root phrases, or
Square root expressions
What I will do is to review them all
I simplify it
We will discuss whether these numbers are relative
Or non-relative
Let's start with A
A = square root of 25
Well, these same as the square root of 5 × 5
The output is clearly 5
We have focused on the positive square root here
Let us now solve B
I will solve B with a different color, and I mean the root
When I say positive square root
B, we have a square root of 24
If what we have to do here, is that we want to get
The fundamentals of this number
If 24, let's extract its factors
It's about 2 x 12
And 12 = 2 x 6
And 6 are 2 x 3
If the square root of 24 is
Square root of 2 × 2 × 2 × 3
That's what the 24-year-old equals
Well, as you see here, we have one full box
So we can rewrite it
This is equivalent to the square root of 2 × 2 ×
Square root of 2 x 3
This is obviously 2
This is the square root of 4
And the square root of 4 = 2
It can not be simplified anymore
We do not see that we have two numbers that can be beaten here by themselves
This will be multiplied by the square root of 6
Or we can write it in the square root of 2 ×
Square root of 3
As I said I now want to determine if the numbers are
Relative or not
This is relative
Part A can be represented as a percentage of two integers
5/1
If this is relative
This is not relative
Non relative
I will not prove this now
But anything is produced from non-relative numbers
A box of any basic number is non-relative
I will not prove this now
This square root for 2 × square root of 3
This is the fact that the square root of 6
This makes it disproportionate
It can not be broken
It can not be expressed as an integer
Another integer as I did there
I will not prove this either
But I do gain some practice
A quick way to do this
You can say that the 4 can be divided into this
4 square full
Let me get the 4 out
I have 4 × 6
The square root of 4 is 2, and we leave the 6 within the root, we get the
Two square roots of 6
That's what you'll see, but I want to
I do it methodically first
Let's move on to section C
Square root of
Again, 20 words are 2 x 10, and 10 are 2 x 5
If this equals the square root of 2 x 2
× 5, is not it?
Now, the square root for 2 × 2, it is clearly
Equals 2
A squared square root of this
Square root for this
2 x square root for 5
Again, you can do this mentally
With little practice
The square root of 20 is 4 × 5
The square root of 4 is 2
We leave the 5 inside the root
Let's now solve section D
We need to find a square root of 200
We follow the same method
Let's take the fundamentals of numbers
It is equal to 2 x 100, and 100 is 2 × 50, which is in turn
2 x 25, and 25 is equal to 5 x 5
If these are the factors, we can write them down
Let me turn right a little
This equals the square root of 2 × 2 × 2
× 5 × 5
Well, we have a full box, and we have
The whole box is here too
If we want to write all the steps, that will be
Square root of 2 × 2 × square root of 2
× Square root of 5 × 5
Square root of 2 × 2 = 2
The square root of 2 is the square root of 2
The square root of 5 × 5, equals the square root of 25
It will be 5
So we can rearrange them
2 x 5 = 10
10 square roots for 2
Again, the number is relative
We can not express it in a fraction that contains correct numbers
Stretch and place
If you want to try to express this number
It will last forever, but it will not be repeated
Well, let's now solve part E
Square root for 2000
I will do it here at the bottom
Part E, square root for 2000
We follow the same way we did recently
We will analyze the number to its initial factors
It is 2 × 1000, and 1000 = 2 × 500, 500 =
2 x 250, 250 = 2 x 125, 125 = 5 x 25
And 25 = 5 × 5
So we finished
If this equals the square root of 2 ×
2 - I will put it between brackets - (2 × 2)
(2 × 2) (2 × 2) (5 × 5)
(5 × 5), right?
We have 1, 2, 3, 4 arcs of number 2 × 2, and three of the number 5 × 5
Now how much is this?
Well, one thing you'll notice is, he can write the output
As follows, this is 4
If we have 4 duplicate
This is equal to the square root of 4 × 4
× Square root of 5 × 5 ×
Square root of 5
As is clear these 4
These are 5
And then x square root of 5
If 4 × 5 = 20 square root of 5
This is not relative again
Non relative
Well, to solve the F
Square root of 1/4, where we can consider it the same
Square root of 1 / square root of 4
And equal to 1/2
As is clear, it is a relative number
Where it can be written as a break
If it is relative
Part G is the square root of 9/4
Square root for 9/4
Same logic
This is equal to the square root of 9 / square root
For 4, equal to 3/2
To solve the part H
Square root of 0.16
You can do this mentally if you have
I absorbed the idea, if I hit 0.4 ×
0.4, I will get this
But I'll show you a more organized way to do this, then
These were not obvious to you
If this equals
Square root of 16/100, right?
This is 0.16
This equals the square root of 16 /
The square root is 100, equal to 4/10, and is equal to 0.4
Let us solve more of these examples
Okay
Part I, a square root of 0.1, equals
The square root of 1/10, is equal
1 / square root of 10, ie 1 / -
Now, the square root of 10 - the 10 is 2 × 5
If that did not help us a lot
The square root of 10 remains as it is
Some math teachers do not want to leave a radical term
In the place
But I can tell you that this is not relative
Non relative
You'll still get setup
You can try this using the calculator, and
Will not be repeated
The calculator will give you a approximation
In order to give you the exact value, it must be
You have an infinite number
But if you want to make it relatively
I will show you
If you want to get rid of root in the
You can hit the square root of 10 /
Square root for 10, is not it?
This is about 1
So you get a square root of 10/10
These two terms are equal, both
Non relative
We take the non-proportional number, divide it by 10, and we will get
On a non-relative number as well
Let's solve J
J
We have a square root of 0.01
This is equal to the square root of 1/100
It is also equal to the square root of 1 / square root
For 100, equal to 1/10, or 0.1
Again it is a relative number
It can be written as a fraction
This number is relatively high
Because it can be written as broken